alors ok on va jouer un jeu qui
s'appelle le bac m nous allons vérifier
si les chroniqueurs ont évidemment
réviser la biographie de black will -
c'est le black m
oui le bac m la question c'est ce qui
marche trois semaines après je suis
tranquillement entre de brûler des
coucougnettes dans une piscine chauffée
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont laissé des messages vous ordre
moral et aux inquiétudes
j'ai l'impression sur le bon chemin
sachez le
je suis j'ai envie de vous dire je suis
porteur de bonnes nouvelles des comptes
quand même qu'on est le seul animateur
dont on applaudit les coucougnettes la
même prouesse aidant faut bien taillé
comme on l'appelle dans le milieu
non la boule de pétanque et une pile le
strike les boules mnm se joue très bien
même si la façon vous faites des
reproches dernières semaines de
téléphonie alors attention je vous le
dis c'est très simple on va jouer donc
haussiers à la black mèche basse qu'il
ya une black mèche juste en dessous
celui qui perdra apportera une blague
matches jusqu'à la fin du match ne soit
pas y revenir très fort cet été toujours
a pas de rattrapage sur le premier qui
si je le fous dehors et je veux entendre
les mouches péter question pour vous
steevy pour quelle occasion black m a
dit c nul quand il a écouté la sexion
d'assaut pour la première fois quand son
fils lui a offert son premier dessin la
gouache ya deux propositions c'est la
réponse à quoi quand il est monté à
écouter la première fois à sexion
d'assaut c'est vrai c'est vrai ça veut
rester à policer c'était au lycée vrai
ça il ya plus deux entre 15 et 20 ans
c'est avec quand on me fait écouter la
première fois je c'est un pote de
l'école tout s'écouter sexion d'assaut
qui cherchait un rappeur il est écouté
tu dis mais c'est nul ouais j'ai pas
aimé au début c'est ouf j'ai pas aimé et
bizarrement quand je les ai rencontrés
feeling lessard est prêt et après tu les
a rencontrés dans la rue dans le même
arrondissement à paris
exactement bah moi comme non pas dans la
rue mais à la rue
[Applaudissements]
ça se joue à ailettes et pourtant c'est
tout à fait différent et a rejoint le
groupe pourrait vous étiez 25 au départ
d'un groupe
ouais ouais ouais 25 ouais il y en a
même que je n'ai même pas connu très
très bien tu vois c'est un gosse était
un collectif à la poste et même sociale
d'un grand collectif de tous les
rappeurs de paris et après quand vous
savez que vous êtes vous avez bas ceux
qui ont le plus persévérer les ce qu'il
y avait une puce la des longs sont
restés voilà voilà
en même temps peut pas aimer le premier
dessin de son fils c'était logique
non c'est attendrissant important vous
avez des enfants ce qu'ils n'ont jamais
menacé pour ça qu'ils c'était un grand
regret non mais ça va arriver a tenté
pas non non non j'ai plus envie
maintenant c'est vrai ah ben non en fait
j'ai gardé mes filleuls il n'y a pas
très longtemps et puis c'est tellement
un boulot à plein temps les enfants que
valence est trop fatigué il appelle
aussi à garder ses filleuls à la semaine
dernière elles ont 58 et ça passe devant
franchement vous n'avez sans rigoler et
elle a changé leur couche c'est à dire
bassée
comment s'appellent les pousses de black
m isabelle morini-bosc djadja ou poux
qui elle s'appelle léa cha cha ou zac
rencontrés sur le tournage du premier
clip de la section ouest et la
maquilleuse et toi tu fais que de
rencontrer des gens de maison et lui bah
voilà où il rencontra gros puisqu'ils
rencontre sa femme et ses débuts donc
ouais faut bien rencontrer les gens ont
des baux sont arrivés nous rencontrent
personnes dans une chanson jazz c'est
une chanson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à voir avec ton ami 6 6 a quelque chose
à voir avec mon ami j'ai comme
l'impression en fait tous étrangers
mais sur ce sujet les travaux s'arrêtent
ici ça rien à voir et après on fait pour
évoluer vers des voies mais j'adore
steevy c'est pour ça qu'on tu n as les
questions pour nicolas pernikoff oui
spécialiste du rap spécialiste doit
encore récolter les bénéfices tout à
l'heure je peux voir les fleurs
paraissent-elles matraquer venait me
chercher et venait me chercher vite une
grande différence
oui surtout quand je vois votre niveau
paddle
[Applaudissements]
ricol s'est amélioré de ouf mais une
semaine a dû tout regard il est bien
meilleur que tout le monde ici bas noirs
et durs mais reçoit de serena williams
[Rires]
la série la 19eme toi choix de naples et
laurent ruquier je te dis jamais ton
tuteur il va smic et était resté lui
serena williams
ah oui ouais ça c'est vrai allez on s'en
fout boutih de quel chanteur était fan
black m john lennon et beatles ou adele
des to be free john lennon des beatles à
et non non non non cette année john
lennon des beatles pour toi aussi je
sais c'est pas ça qui va lancer sa olala
c'est du dos et pour le coup c'est à
faire qu'à balancer sa gamine elle fait
ouais c'est vrai que quand c'est sorti
les boys band on était petit on a bien
sûr on a dance qui fait des bonnes monde
akio bien sûr au début était un peu
donne une de vos chansons préférées
c'est une chanson d g squad aucune
chaîne au monde vrai ou faux simon est
allé en corse où il allait faire et je
vais montrer aux téléspectateurs
regardent et voilà bonsoir ça va t'il
famille mais ça va merci à l'émeute et
medic
voilà son problème sans problème il a
été résumée en quelques années c'est
bien adèle des to be free bien au genre
ton oui ça marche rappelons que j'avais
une mauvaise nouvelle ça va mais c'est
chaud avec son collègue sur le régime et
qui peut parler de match on doit au
niveau des vannes commis par le juge il
parlait lui sur le tard et doit comme
pagnol
[Applaudissements]
ces jeunes gens appartenant toutes à
caen joue bien mais tu vas voir il est
très sympa mais ça va vous faire sur la
traînant sur la fin de ma mère quand tu
as un truc jour le chemin de traverse
jamais regardé j'ai très chaud c'est ça
mais j'ai 17ans book comtal aussi pas
mal mais ça je me changeais jeu tu vas
passer tu vas l'échangé revenir après
d'accord le tandis que ça va sinon
pauvres emmanuelli ou passionnés non
seulement ça coûte cher et en plus cette
merde aux malades mais les mecs j'ai
foyer est au plus tard je voyais le gars
de plus le fait que la couleur soit
collège et très chaud c'était pour la
pluie s'est pas fait par des jeunes à
santiago avant de poser la question à
laquelle sommités de télévision black m
at il appris à rapper la cam
c'est à julien lepers unique michel gueu
michel drucker julien lepers non non non
ok si c'était dans l'aventuré robinson
sur tmz sortie en salles où il est sorti
une semaine aux îles fidji en son nom
alors j'adore julien lepers mais quand
on te dit tu vas partir une semaine à
grandir le maire fera seulement étaient
tous là c'est tout cela que ya beaucoup
de gens qui m'ont dit ouais ça va être
chaud de te retrouver que j'adore mais
ça veut dire hein ah bah ouais ouais
moi
il était adorable c'est un amour tu
donnes un amour de mecs c'est que je la
norme à sa patte et vraiment je
l'adorent génial eh bien c'est lui
julien dray tu t'écoutes actif et a
passé une semaine et que tu ne le perd
ouais j'ai kiffé d'où on a galéré un peu
sur l'île mais c'était cool c'est cool
ça semaine sur moi j'aime bien moi je
serais allé parce que je les adore mais
si vous devez passer une semaine sur une
île où ce serait avec qui hakim jonathan
cohen
ah ouais pas très dur il partira bien le
problème avec isabelle moi j'aimerais
away obama va lancer ce film si vous
partez tous les deux vous êtes sûr que
lille restera désert